D
SAY THERE NO NEED FOR US REHASH
IT HERE BUT LET GET SOME
ANALYSIS FROM REPUBLICAN SENATOR
OF ARKANSAS.
YOU HEARD WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAD
TO SAY.
YOU WERE CRITICAL OF HIM EARLIER
TODAY FOR ATEPID RESPONSE.
HE CLEARLY UPPED A BIT TO
BLOCKING SANCTIONS ON BANKS.
IS THAT ENOUGH?
>> NO, JOHN AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
IS NOT.
I MEAN, AT LEAST STEP IN RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I WOULDN'T EVEN CALL HALF
MEASURE PROBABLY MORE LIKE
QUARTER MEASURE.
SANCTIONS ON COUPLE OF BANKS AND
SOME OLIGARCHS.
I HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR MONTH
NOW FOR THE KIND OF PUNISHING
SANCTIONS THAT JOE BIDEN AND
WESTERN LEADERS KEEP PROMISE BUT
NEVER REVEALING.
PERMANENTLY CANCELLING THE NORTH
STREAM TWO PIPELINE NOT JUST
SHUFFLING SOME PAPER AROUND ITS
REVIEW.
IMPOSING SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA OIL
AND GAS SECTORS IT IS ITS
MINERAL AND MINING SECTORS.
THE CRITICAL INDUSTRY IN THAT
COUNTRY CLAIMING DOWN FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY AND ITS ACCESS TO THE
INTERNATIONAL BANK IS SYSTEM.
THESE ARE KIND OF SANCTIONS THAT
ARE CALLED FOR NOW NOT THESE
QUARTER MEASURES THAT WERE JUST
ANNOUNCED OR THAT BERLIN
ANNOUNCED EARLIER TODAY.
I MEAN UNFORTUNATELY THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID 24 HOURS
DEBATING WHETHER TO EVEN CALL
THIS INVASION AN INVASION.
AND PRESIDENT TOOK 80 MINUTES TO
COME OUT FOR HIS OWN PRESS
CONFERENCE WHICH DOESN'T EXACTLY
PROJECT CONFIDENCE AND
RESOLUTION TO PEOPLE WATCHING.
SO MUCH MORE CALLED FOR RIGHT
NOW THAN WHAT WE JUST HEARD.
>> SANDRA: WE WILL SEE IF THAT
HAPPENS.
PRESIDENT SAID TO PUT SIMPLY
RUSSIA CAR OF OUT BIG CHUNK OF
UKRAINE SAYING VERY DEFINITIVE,
SAYING THIS IS BIG BEGINNING OF
RUSSIA INVASION OF UKRAINE AND
THEN ANNOUNCED I AM GOING TO
BEGIN IMPOSE SANCTIONS THAT GO
BEYOND THOSE IMPLEMENTED IN
2014.
DO YOU BELIEVE ANYTHING THERE
THAT PRESIDENT SAID WILL BOTHER
THE KREMLIN?
>> AGAIN, I'M AFRAID NOT.
EVEN PHRASING HE USED BEGINNING
INVASION.
IT IS INVASION.
IT IS NOT BEGINNING OF ANYTHING.
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND RUSSIA'S
LEADERS HAVE MADE CLEAR THAT
THEY VIEW NOT JUST TERRITORY
UNDER THE CONTROL OF APPROXIMATY
OF MILITARY FORCES THEY HAVE
BEEN BACKING FOR EIGHT YEARS NOW
SEPARATE FROM UKRAINE BUT
TERRITORY THAT UKRAINE CONTROLS
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE PUTTING
HEAVY ARMORED SOLDIERS IN
VEHICLES AND WEAPONS.
INTO THESE TWO PROVE IS VINCE IN
EASTERN UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY
PREPARE THEY ARE PREPARING TO
INVADE EVEN DEEPER IN UKRAINE
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE ALL OF
THOSE TROOPS STATIONED JUST
NORTH OF THE CAPITAL CITY.
THEY WHY THEY HAVE SO MANY OF
NAVY SHIPS IN BLACK SEA.
UKRAINE HAS BEEN INVADED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HIS WESTERN
COUNTERPARTS SWIFT AND SEVERE
SANCTIONS WHAT THAT HAPPENED.
IN FIRST 24 HOURS, THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FAR FROM WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN I SUSPECT
VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL EMBOLDENED
TAKE FURTHER AGGRESSION AGAINST
UKRAINE.
SENATOR, THE PRESIDENT IF YOU GO
FURTHER INCURSIONS OR FURTHER
INVASION OF UKRAINE WE ARE GOING
HIT YOU WITH MORE SANCTIONS
MAYBE VLADIMIR PUTIN SEES THE
LIGHT.
LET'S JUST SAY FOR TALKING
PURPOSES HERE.
HE SEES LIGHTS SAYS I AM NOT
GOING INVADE.
HOW DO YOU GET HIM OUT OF WHERE
HE IS NOW?
THEY TRIED GET HIM OUT OF
CRIMEA.
HE WON'T BUDGE.
HIS RESPONSE WAS ANNEX THE
PLACE.
WHAT'S THE STOP HIM FROM DOING
THE SAME THING.
THAT'S IT.
BUT I AM NEVER LEAVING.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK HE WILL
SEE THE LIGHT.
THAT YOU CAN ALREADY SEE THAT
THE KIND OF TIMID RESPONSE THAT
WEST HAS MOUNTED THE PRIME
MINISTER OF ITALY JUST A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO SAID WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE ANY SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA'S
ENERGY SECTOR.
THAT'S WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE PUT THOSE SANCTIONS ON
THE TABLE NOW.
AT LEAST AT MINIMUM ANNOUNCE
WHAT THEY WILL BE.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE
POLITICAL WILL TO IMPOSE THEM
NOW.
BECAUSE, SILENCE TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS DEAFENING.
HE CAN SEE THAT INTERNAL
DIVISIONS AMONG THE WEST.
AND HE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
EXPLOITS THOSE DIVISIONS.
>> WHAT ELSE WAS STRUCK ME SOME
THING WE TALKED ABOUT IN ADVANCE
OF THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS, WHAT
HE WILL SAY TO REASSURE
AMERICANS THAT THIS CONFLICT AND
THIS INVASION OVER THERE WON'T
RUN OF PRICES MUCH MORE HERE.
WHAT HE IS DOING ABOUT IT.
HE SAID WE ARE CLOSELY
MONITORING ENERGY SUPPLIERS
AROUND THE WORLD AND I AM
THINKING, WE ARE ONE OF THEM.
AND WE HAVE SHOWN THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO SUPPLY THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY WE NEED IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT DOING THAT TODAY.
TO AT.WE IMPORTING OIL FROM
FOREIGN NATIONS INCLUDING
RUSSIA.
SO, WHY NOT STRONGER MESSAGE
THERE FOR AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
HE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE PRICES
DON'T KEEP GOING UP.
WHY DIDN'T HE ANNOUNCE WE ARE
GOING START PUMPING MORE OIL?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY PRICES
PUMP ARE GOING TO GO UP.
BUT REMEMBER THIS WERE GOING UP
FOR FIRST YEAR THAT BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LONG BEFORE THIS
MOMENT.
THAT INFLATION DIRECT RESULT OF
THE HOSTILE CITIES THAT BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REALLY
PROGRESSIVE LEFT IN AMERICA HAS
TOWARDS OIL AND GAS.
WE STILL POWERS OUR ECONOMY AS
MUCH AS THEY MAY NOT LIKE THAT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST MORE AMERICAN
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION.
TAKE OFF ALL OF THE REGULATORY
RED TAPE IN TERMS OF PRODUCE OIL
AND GAS.
EDDED BY ADMINISTRATION.
OTHERWISE LEFT TAKING US DOWN
THE PATH OF GERMANY.
WHICH BUILT ALL OF THOSE
PIPELINES TO RUSSIA WHICH CLOSED
DOWN ALL OF ITS NUCLEAR PLANTS
AND NOW THEY ARE WITH A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER.
THAT'S LAST PLACE AMERICA SHOULD
EVER BE.
SINCE WE ARE BLESSED WITH SO
MUCH OIL AND GAS IN COUNTRY USE
FOR OTHER SAFETY AND OUR PROSPER